so we have catalogued dysfunction in dc
nothing new but very dispiriting talked
about how omicron wildly contagious and
you know it should take precautions but
probably gonna get it so we're trying
now to to end on uplifting notes here on
the forward podcast and i'm going to
make a case that that is i hope very
upbeat and positive which is that the
new spider-man movie
is something we should be excited about
on a couple of levels no spoilers right
no spoilers no no spoilers so number one
this movie did gangbusters business uh
it is the second biggest opening of all
time it beat out avengers infinity war
it's right behind end game and just goes
to show that if you have
a compelling offering and people will
still come out in droves to go to a real
life in-person movie theater spend some
of their hard earned money put their
butt in that seat and watch what i will
say i saw this movie it is a very very
uh excellent movie
and so number one there there is still
hope for real life in-person experiences
uh like movie theaters that's good i
think they did a really good job
marketing it too between
the lead characters dating and the the
roll out i think they let a lot you mean
that pretend romance no i'm kidding it
seems real it might be fake if it's fake
i bought it hook line and sinker baby oh
it seems real it seems real you know one
of the most uplifting
pieces of content on the internet if you
haven't seen it you should go to see it
right now is the lim lip sync battle
between
tom holland and zendaya the singing in
the rain
uh video zach do you know what i'm
talking about i do and tom holland
was showed to me that how talented he
was without you know a side of him i
hadn't seen before at least when i first
watched it if you don't know what andrew
yang is talking about right now
just go to youtube and google singing in
the rain tom holland and you will be
glad you did because it's the most
delightful four minutes of content and
so you see future boyfriend and
girlfriend tom holland and zendaya in a
lip sync battle they're both phenomenal
but tom holland kind of next levels this
thing he does something
that
in a way
it kind of sets such a high water mark
for a lip sync battle that there's no
place to go but but down you know what i
mean like you already kind of like
like
defined the form and then everyone else
is a panel limitation anyway
so
check that out that that that'll be a
bit of uplift for sure um but the the
second reason why i think that this
movie is such an exciting marker for the
future is that it does things that no
one thought were possible
and that's kind of what we need in
american life today i'm going to just
throw the you know a couple parallels
it's like you have this dysfunctional
duopoly and it's like oh we're trudging
along and everyone's sad and then andrew
yang comes along and was like hey let's
start a new party the forward party and
let's by the way try and make it so that
new parties can emerge that aren't just
us like you know anyone who wants like a
vibrant system and then people are like
oh oh it's not possible it can't be done
there is stuff that goes on in this
movie that you would legitimately say
like this should not cannot be possible
like
things that some
uh
fan fiction writer even they would be
like there's no way like like this thing
just doesn't seem and and they did it in
like a major major tent poll like uh you
know what like at this point uh maybe
like a franchise defining tent pole um
they just pushed so many boundaries they
integrated different
uh
worlds and universes
um and so right now you have this
political universe that is so staid
and insular and it's like beltway this
and like you know like uh cable news
that and and then there's this entire
world outside of it that we need to kind
of combine and integrate
with the world of politics it's
happening in media you can sense it
there's some like alternative media
voices that are just rising in
popularity because people are so tired
of the nonsense and the bs
and so you can imagine what like a
normal
uh spider-man movie would would be like
and now it would just seem like such a
crushing disappointment compared to what
this what they did with this movie like
uh so
it's it's kind of funny to say but like
i feel like
this movie
gives you like a sense of what's
actually possible if for example
a couple of major movie studios let's
call them sony and marvel got together
combined all their ip took like you know
20 years of movie history and like
smashed them all together
if if sony and marvel can do it
maybe
you know the american people can do it
too maybe like ford and
libertarians and socialists and
democrats and republicans and
independents can all make it happen
wow that's like
frankly
not that they need it because it looks
like they're killing it but that's a
pretty ringing endorsement for a movie
andrew um from you so
um
i was gonna see it this week maybe i'll
go tonight maybe i'm not like you know
get out of my chair but i didn't like
freaking send us your review man you can
text me because that that movie was like
there were a number of times watching
the movie i was like i can't believe i'm
seeing this
like it's
like this stuff that you would imagine
in a dream and then like they invested
you know whatever like tens hundreds of
millions of dollars in it
i love it man and i like it we're ending
this on uplifting things i'm gonna
rattle off a couple too uh we have an
hiv vaccine in the works that's looking
really positive and it's the same mrna
technology using the covidvax
that
seems to be working it's not official
yet but it's in we're in human trials at
this point which is super exciting
there's a company called air company
which you know can debate the name that
makes alcohol out of air have you seen
this
no but i like it i would and i would
experience but it's crazy that they're
creating a product that doesn't that's
like
extremely good for the environment to
produce or no no cost to the environment
um now i've not tried this i need to buy
it um to test it out and maybe it's mad
expensive i'm not sure but i like the
trend of companies like that making
money
selling a product people need with
basically no like carbon neutral
look at you promoting air alcohol you
don't know about it and you have
about it but it's still cool it's
worth trying right it sounds cool
forward sponsored by air alcohol air
company air company if you're listening
to this we would love a sponsorship um
and the other one i'll leave you with is
this stuff just fascinates me
there is a professor eduardo fernandez
who the director of neuroengineering at
the university of miguel hernandez in
spain
who
has gotten us one step closer to helping
blind people see he's basically created
this like
i don't want to call it a bionic eye
because that's too far in but basically
instead of trying to fabricate
yeah i guess so instead of recreating
the eye though it's like plugging into
your nerves and then there's a there's a
yeah there's a camera that's like
sending but it's using the brain signals
that we normally get from our eye um
to help your brain interpret what's
going on out in the world um and it's
it's in a woman's it's been implanted in
a woman's head and she's like
had like pretty good success
and then the first thing she does the
first thing she does is she goes to a
police station
leans into the desk and says
i'll be back
and then walks out and then crash the
car through the front maybe
maybe
which is this terminator 2. that's
that's that's one brother
[Laughter]
there's been way too many terminator
movies they've tried it's like all these
future movies you see people get healed
real quickly and i just don't think
we've gotten there yet um but i think
we're we're poised to take a leap um
whether it's their stuff in spinal cord
injuries or bionic eyes or bionic limbs
well we're slowing and reversing brain
aging man i mean that's like the main
one like that my guy is working on at
mit
uh you know and and you should know
andrew yang is not one of those
uh like people who's like we're gonna
live forever we do all the stuff it's
like you know like i like i'm i'm not
that guy
but
but but but if we can
uh
slow down
uh deterioration and that leads to
alzheimer's and the rest of it i mean
that that's gonna just save save lives
and like improve people's quality of
life in like an enormous way
[Music]
you